that's my aunt and uncle arguing
upstairs yeah he shat on the living room
floor again he shat on the living room
floor
whoa says our hero it says our camera so
rude of me
hello guys righteous the Ryan the right
is here and I'm sorrow Magnus
tyro Magnus is here Tyron Magnus is on a
journey to 1 million subscribers and I
thought we have a very similar fan base
this will help him in no way because he
already has all you guys as fans for a
lot of you today as big as you are a lot
of people still don't know about me I'm
in New Jersey right now where Tyrone
lives I wanted to take a little trip
here just to see him and I brought my
girlfriend here so she could endure all
the gay jokes we're making we're gonna
check out the official red band trailer
for the nice guys red damn violent
sexuality nudity and drug use aunt Lee
brief them equity quality of being calm
who is it
messenger service even-tempered March
we're gonna play again - give me one
else I'll shut up unless you mean I love
that game their private investigator
just twenty bucks in there I just take
it not my ear for that i messenger give
me a left arm no come on Deep Ellum you
have a spiral front you know deep breath
I do that Russell Crowe will get John
pages as he got trouble with someone
might ask around for me
Jackson Healy I work for the Department
of Justice my daughter Amelia is in
danger please find her protect her March
Jackie Lee I'm not either urges and I
ask you a question do you think I am I
got a license to carry dumb ass and ever
since your little visit this little
baby's gonna stay right here what the
blood trust say you're pretty good at
this I want you to fighting me I
would've thought your job ended with
breaking my [ __ ] arm you're the guy
who beat up my dad hey sucker punched
your dad big difference
I've seen this girl's got dark hair eyes
Amelia what's in it for me he'll stop
doing it deal what there's like horse
here and stuff we don't know many times
have I told you don't say and stuff just
and dad there are horses the mob is
trying to spread its operation to Los
Angeles somehow amelia is involved one
thing we know for sure
something funny's do wanna nice the
world's worst
look at the bright side nobody got hurt
sugar glider I'm saying I think they
died quickly though so I don't think
that they got hurt
that looks awesome to me I don't know
how you feel about it but that is
totally my kind of film it's more
interesting to me I'm not sure what -
well that pisses me off that you don't
feel the same way as I do the fact that
we have a difference of opinion is so
upsetting to me you know I'm just gonna
post in your comment section your
[ __ ] an [ __ ] a dick you don't
know anything about movies and I'm gonna
unsubscribe from you because we have a
difference of opinion why would you even
that's the most logical thing to do dude
everybody's doing I never joke about
doing that to me tight enough sorry Tara
that was just sorry I mean to hurt your
feelings that gentle sensitive so I
catch my breath I do love Ryan Gosling
and what I love about him is he's
usually in these very serious roles and
it's cool to see him doing something
that's a lot more fun like he's
partnering up a Russell Crowe so I felt
like oh they're both probably gonna be
like badasses but he's not a badass in
this movie you know he's more of the the
comedic relief next to tough guy Russell
Crowe
I like chunky Russell Crowe actually
like chunky tough [ __ ] you up kind of
Russell Crowe that I think he looks cool
in that role yeah I didn't expect the
Ryan Gosling to be playing there cuz
it's he's doing this such comedy there's
like some physical comedy to like that
bit when he's on the toilet and I've
never seen him do like physical kind of
comedy before right the director and
co-writer of this Shane black I mean he
delete the weapon and that was like you
know Marta rigs Murtagh were essentially
us you know sigh create great
back-and-forth between the two
characters he did the same thing with
KITT every scene Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
I've done Kiss Kiss Bang Bang you
and back and forth too by the way ah oh
oh you set me up okay perfect
alright perfect he said back and forth
there's a back and forth joke here
somewhere
like you pick balls Jonna something feel
free to rock on the side for the joke
and you have to I don't know where are
we back and forth help us out here
comment below what you think of the joke
of it yes
you know Iron Man 3 I like the dynamics
he created with Rhodey and Tony Stark I
thought their friendship and their their
chemistry and their dialogue off each
other was a lot more fun and dynamic
yeah so he's good with buddy movies yeah
he's good with these buddy types of
films I'm like unlikely people pairing
up with each other
the 70s vibe I like your 70s child yes
did not 1977 so you could be a black DJ
I could be Wow you could grow afro
couldn't you yeah I could have you I
have before yes did it match downstairs
ah no no I could keep that man skate
I imagine no matter how big it gets
it'll still look large the it's you know
like a mine looks like a little Chinese
boy
yeah redwood surrounded by ferns so it
pretty much looks like like mine redwood
surrounded by firms
firms just here yes it said always no
matter how much hair always looks big so
I was just like it's huge friendly small
firms that's the hair biceps are huge
biceps are huge you were wearing a long
sleeve shirt and I was like holy [ __ ]
his arms like huge Rena
no there's like fake athletic fit
question yesterday I was like I'm not
even flexing but just look what happens
in my arm was gonna wear t-shirt it's
cold out scold outside school in the
East Coast guys I need to move to
California
you're the earthquake's Abbi Coleman
ringing stardom and you endure all the
cocaine on the East Coast and hey thinks
there's a lot cocaine over here I've
never heard that before there is I
thought surely this guy knows I got the
hookups
what do you think Rick what they were
ready to react right now guys we think
that Star Wars video he did was all
natural no no works it was he was coked
out of his mind when he did that I'm
high off life man yeah doesn't but
positive vibe rainbows here dude yeah no
that that's the LSD that you take that
makes you see that dude I told you
you're trippin too much sorry
we're like barely reviewing the video it
has all those qualities I like of a film
it looks badass it looks fun it looks
like there's an intriguing mystery kind
of story at the same time the production
design of the 70s looks authentic and
vibrant caning me a favor can you bounce
your chest for us Wow baby is this
turning you want go uh-huh yeah like
that I know you're talking it's IRA come
out you're talking to Tyrone about that
aren't you Wow she's saying is it so big
it looks like there's a little person
inside way to compliment him look at
that his bicep is going through his long
sleeve and it's bigger than mine with my
arm showing I mean pretty you busts it
make good have you seen yours I've never
good bison yeah but you like these you
got a pretty good peek there I do
yeah that's pretty good peak uh how
sweet that comes welcome better yogi a
better peak than a white I may have
bigger overall arms you free measured
but you got better peak to me I got a
better peak but you get this genetic man
Caterpie you have a big peak you got one
who's a dick joking this Oh comment
below and tell me connectivity yo Brian
is a bad ass martial artist man this guy
don't sleep on don't meet him in public
and make a pass at Baraka he will [ __ ]
you up
the us'll I know you're into wrestling
with Russell hot chicks man that's what
Dad that's not sure we were wrestling
last night no I don't wrestle though now
oh I had a friend I offered to teach me
grappling all MMA stuff kickboxing I
just never took you I could teach a to
wrestle uh I can teach at a wrestle
Veronica I could really teach our man
and I need your help Veronica I can woo
get the hell off of me hmm no one too
uncomfortable too much I feel viola have
you ever seen a buff guy get that enough
for my wife serves ever in my life you
you're being to ball wrecking Ryan space
this is all the things you say to me off
camera so the fact that fact that you're
now exposing me like that on cameras
it's with my masculinity from me
front of all America
jokes about Tyrone being molested by me
are cracking him up free anyway guys
listen thanks for tuning in to the real
rejects if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become a reject it's fun
it's a good time
Tyrone Magnus has a channel that all of
you already know about if you haven't
subscribed yet I don't know why you
haven't quit being an [ __ ] and do it
subscribe so he can get to 1 billion
subscribes to this man personally oh
yeah I really gotta go even though
you're like that you just put your
finger up I go like this it doesn't me
like you know why guys when they imitate
black guys now the hands are always like
when we don't really do that well you
know yeah less subtle you know small iam
so I am like you there wait wait now
that is pop now that you're my black
friend can am I not allowed to say the
word no you cannot say that I can't say
to this day still can't say it the
woman's de jure is not even with 1/8
hint is the black coalition of America
has not decided whether or not our non
black friends can say the word so till
then just consider it off limits and I
try baby I can't say the n-word
i blurt out all the time when you're not
around Tyrone's i call all my friends
hey RR
my name is jack and i love watching you
guys watch other guys and so on for some
reason plus your last name oh you guys
are super entertaining and i like that
you guys know your [ __ ] when it comes to
movies that's probably why i watch your
material more than anyone elses ah more
than you Tyrone I win I got Jack I'm
really having some trouble sort of
lifting off with my artwork being a
struggling artist at all most of it is
mainly centered towards film and
television characters Edyta duh knowing
you guys are the audience yeah throw a
link at the description box yep ok dude
before I look at your art I'm gonna have
to see what you look like first time I
don't know why I have this on my channel
but I swear 98% of the subscribers look
like serial killers look at him don't
you get a serial killer vibe
you ever seen Ryan with a straight face
he looks kind of serial killers do like
attracts like you listen I'm gonna put
your link in the description box
facebook.com slash only human art no he
does have some cool art I will put a
link in there if you draw a photo of
Tyrone and I not doing something gay
yeah no don't do it image Veronica's
probably going to use it for pleasure or
so if you do so don't do it oh well in
that case make as many drawings as you
want as many positions as you can come
up with that your impression of fluid my
name is IRA you know I never thought
about Veronica's sex toast like that
Oh everyone's on a jet joking me yeah
it's like Veronica's next oh yeah you
know that as I do there you go over
there no they don't call her that's like
her porn star name it's like really easy
don't like sex toes some people are into
that yeah if you can call her sex toes
can I say the n-word [ __ ] this we know
you managed to drop it Johnny sure